[Music]
15 plus 10 let's go
okay black against sultan
from
azerbaijan okay so e4 again we've played
quite a few things in the speed run
let's start with the sicilian let's uh
i'm in the mood for a combative game
let's go for a sicilian
okay knight c3 so knight c3
is the jumping off point for a bunch of
different lines right
you might recognize this as the
introduction to the grand prix but it's
also just a very tricky move order kind
of move because
white on the next move can develop the
other knight and then transition back to
an open sicilian with d4 so the way that
you respond to the move knight c3
basically depends on which sicilian you
play against knight f3 and i'll explain
that a little bit more after the game
the move that i
have liked for a very long time with
black it's actually the early a6
variation this is not the most common
move
most people here go knight c6 or they go
d6
but a6 in my opinion is very very
underrated because if you're a night or
player this move makes a lot of sense
but even if you're not an idol player
it's a good way to combat the grand prix
attack in the closest ceiling basically
the point
is that you go for an early b5 you
expand on the queen side
quickly and early
and of course you get for yourself a
nice development square for your light
squared bishop so we're going to play
bishop b7 fiance
and then we're going to work on the
king's side so bishop g2
how do we how exactly do we position our
pieces here so
i'm going to put together a setup that i
was taught many years ago
now if you play the sicilian regularly
you should know
that
these two pawns e7 and d7
often go on d6 and e6 creating what's
more not exactly but kind of like this
uh chevening and pawn structure
and the reason you do that is because
those pawns control a lot of very
important center squares it looks
passive
but in reality it's it's part of the
heart and soul of the sicilian so we can
start with knight f6
we're not fearing e5 because the bishop
on g2 hangs yeah we can start with
knight f6 we can start with d6
we can even start with e6
i like the concept of starting with
either d6 or e6 for maximum flexibility
let's start with d6 let's play d6 the
other benefit of the move d6 of course
is that it creates a potential
development square
for the other knight on d7
and in in such positions the knight
actually often goes to d7 and not c6
because developing the knight to c6 kind
of blocks in the bishop uh in kind of an
awkward way
okay so now we can go e6 or we can go
knight f6 i think it really doesn't
matter all that much let's play e6 and
sort of in the spirit of the variation
hopefully it makes sense like why we're
positioning these pawns on d6 and e6
also it creates breathing room for our
king side pieces now we can actually
get the bishop out yeah f4
okay now finally i think the time has
come for us to begin to begin our
development knight f6
the other thing that we often do in this
variation is we position the queen on c7
we position the queen on c7 um let's
before we do that
before we do that let's get our
bishop out let's get our bishop out to
e7 just to prepare the castle
white castles
and
this actually is already a good time to
play the move queen c7 so queen c7 is
basically i would say played for three
reasons the first is of course the fact
that it potentially coordinates the
rooks like after we develop the night
castle the rooks are connected the
second is that in conjunction with the
knight on d7 both of these pieces
control the e5 square making it harder
for white to break through in the center
with e4e5 otherwise a very nasty idea in
such positions
and the third reason is that um
what is the third reason so it controls
e5 it connects the rooks
and i guess it's just like it's just
better placed on c7 than on d than on d8
um it's it's more prepared for the
action so we can play queen c7 complain
ipd7
i think that starting with a
developing move makes more sense than
starting with a queen move this is more
flexible because
we know that we're going to want to play
this move anyway
h3 so white is preparing king side
expansion with g4
that's fine that does not
disturb us let's go queen c7
yeah reason number three is actually
reason number one and two combined
so you might kind of
notice some parallels between the setup
that we have
decided on and the hedgehog or maybe the
hippo
and the reason you
are are noticing that is because i think
these pawns on e6 and d6 create that
idea that it's similar to the hipaa but
in reality it's it's its own thing
knight e2 now we can choose which side
to castle castling queenside is
incredibly risky in such positions
because
these two pawns can serve as hooks white
can use them to open up files very
easily on the queen side whereas
castling kingside is definitely safer in
such positions but that doesn't mean
that we can never castle queenside
now
it would be very interesting here i
think to prevent white from playing g4
so i think we're going to make a very
risky move but hopefully a move that
throws our opponent off just a little
bit we are going to play h5
and for now we're going to keep our king
in the center
for now we're going to keep parking in
the center now i'm not that i wasn't
that scared of g4 but i want to see how
our opponent reacts to this move we're
going to try to be as annoying as
possible with the move h5
it's risky because now castling kingside
is going to be involved with a
tremendous amount of risk
so maybe we actually will end up
castling queenside and
you know
basically telling why i'd come to papa
come at me bro
a4
but a4 might be a little bit premature
how should we respond to this what
should black do here
the move is pretty straightforward
yeah we should play b4 we should try to
keep the queen side closed especially
because we are already kind of
uh our intuition is
heavily pointing in the direction of
castling queenside now c3
allows a very interesting idea so when i
see the move c3 the first thing i notice
and i know a lot of you are probably
tempted to play a5 here if i'm reading
the room correctly
but when i see the move c3 the first
thing i notice is that the pawn on d3
has been weakened
now that might not seem relevant because
black cannot attack that pawn with the
pieces but black
you know attacking upon with pieces
isn't the only way to exploit a weak
pawn
we can also use our own pawns to
undermine our opponent's pawn structure
so what move does that suggest
what move does that suggest
yeah the move that it suggests is c4
but i think that before we play c4
it's worthwhile to take on c3 because if
we had played c4 immediately as you can
see it would have potentially dropped
would have potentially dropped the b4
pawn now we play c4 with a clean
conscience
and i already think that white is in a
little bit of trouble in the center
notice how nicely our minor pieces are
all positioned the queen is protecting
c4 the bishop and the knight are both
aiming at e4 they used to be biting on
granite but now what they're doing makes
a lot of sense because the d3 pawn is
now incredibly weak if white's pawn
could shift back to c2 all of white's
problems would be solved that is the
power of pawn chains
and the potential danger of
reducing the size of your pawn chain
they become easier to undermine knight
g5
a good way to protect preemptively
protect the pawn on e4
but it allows us the possibility of
continuing to put pressure on white's
center right that's what we tried to do
with the move c4 so we should try to be
consecutive here what seems to be
a natural follow-up to the move c4 and
don't rush to take the pawn on d3 right
that that should not be
something that you're doing
automatically a lot of you are saying d5
d5 is bad because it allows white to
play e5 and close down the center that
has the opposite effect the move is
knight c5 exactly you're bringing the
knight into the game
you're putting more pressure on d3
you're actually threatening now to
capture the pawn and if the d3 pawn
moves then we can take on e4 a classic
way to force white's hand
and already you can see how much
pressure we're putting on white's
position white is a lot more space
yeah so so i'll talk about this after
the game the reason i did i don't take
on d3 first
is because it allows the white's queen
to get into the action if you take first
and play knight c5 yeah you're playing
knight c5 with tempo and so a lot of you
guys are succumbing to one move itis
you're saying oh i play knight e5 and i
attack the queen
but the queen simply steps back to c2
and you have reduced the number of
white's targets from two to one right
the pawn on d3 is itself a target you
shouldn't rush to take it
and
this creates an ultimatum where yeah
white can play dc and conserve his pawns
but after we take on e4 white's white
has the short end of the stick
in all regards he's lost the center pawn
and white right remains with a very very
bad pawn structure on the queen side
so this is a good example of being
patient and evaluating all of your
options rather than just reducing the
tension immediately and making the
tempting move
yeah as charlie would say bishop on b7
definitely qualifies as a narrative
super shooter and we've actually gotten
our opponent to think for the first time
this game which is a pretty good sign
morocci says but what if the center
opens and our king is still not castled
so a lot of people have this fear of
keeping the king in the center i've
talked about this before when you hit
like intermediate level you need to be
comfortable in certain situations
actually not castling at all you are
allowed to keep your king in the center
it is not against the rules of chess so
if the center is closed and you feel
that both flanks are dangerous
the lesser evil actually might be
keeping the king in the center now that
has the downside of not connecting your
rooks right as long as your king is in
the center the rooks are disconnected
but that's not necessarily
you know mission critical to the
position e5 okay so now things get fun
white tries to open up the center
this position is all about order of
operations we just need to figure out
what should we do first what should we
capture first
so we essentially have two options we
can play bishop takes g2
or we can play
d takes e5 first we want to weigh the
pros and cons of each option so to me
the tempting move seems to be bishop
takes g2 because that reduces the bishop
tension so bishop takes g2
if white plays e takes f6 then we can
simply take the rook on f1 and at the
end we're up in exchange
so that's basically a no-brainer let's
take on g2 first
let's eliminate the headache of having
to worry about the bishops and now let's
think
so now the options again are as follows
we can play c takes d3 and take that
pawn attack in the knight or
we can play d takes e5
so if we play d takes e5 white's gonna
play f takes e5 and then if we grab that
pawn with a queen i will be worried
about the placement of the queen in that
position white also has the fork d4
now after d4 the line does not end who
can tell me
how black can salvage the piece in that
position after takes takes takes and d4
yeah you can give a check on d5 but the
king drops back to g1 and that queen on
d5 worries me i feel like that queen is
not optimally placed because it's
subject to potentially annoying moves
such as knight f4 the knight of four
does
hang the knight on g5 so
honestly this does seem like a pretty
darn good option
but i much prefer the option of taking
on d3 actually i think this is much much
better i'm almost certain of it
because this is simpler this is simpler
and it keeps our center intact
essentially after e takes f6
we can just play d takes e2
and after queen takes c2 we take back on
f6 we are still up a pawn
but we still have this pawn mass in the
center that keeps our king very very
safe
white on the other hand
yeah has a pawn mass around their king
but that's a lot more attackable because
the g file is going to be open
so let's play d2
yeah so we should seriously consider
after queen takes e2 the pres the
possibility of taking on f6 with the
bishop
taking on f6 of the bishop has the
benefit of attacking c3
it also has the benefit of quote unquote
keeping your pawn structure
intact on the king side
but remember you are not just trying to
you know in the sicilian the priority is
rarely to keep your pawns as intact as
possible very often if you're a sicilian
player you should know this very often
this pawn formation which arises
frequently in the rouser or the
classical sicilian which i've played in
blitz
is actually better than this pawn
formation shifting the pawn from g7 to
f6 in a way actually improves the health
of black's pawn structure there's a
couple of reasons for that the first is
that more pawns equals more safety to
the king right the king is just safer
surrounded by pawns the second thing is
that it opens the g-file and in this
particular instance we can actually use
the g-file as a direct avenue to white's
king
but the third thing is that when pawns
are doubled and i've explained this
before you can use the
the pawn that's in front can be used as
either a battering ram you can basically
push it without compromising your king's
safety
right you basically have this free pawn
that you can push and do stuff with and
you don't have to worry about opening up
your king because you have another pawn
that stands behind it so in this case
what move am i talking about this is a
positional move
it's a positional move it sets up an
outpost
it sets up an outpost we play the move
f5
we set up the outpost on e4 for the
knight
now you might say well didn't i just say
that we can use the g file rook g8 is
not going anywhere right we can play
rook chain on the next move we're sort
of masking our intentions on the king
side
we're saving rook g8 for a rainy day
f5 is a really really strong move and
this is why it's better to take with a
pawn in f6
can't the knight come back to g5 it
absolutely can maybe it even will
but
we can chase the knight away with f6 or
we can simply eliminate the knight with
our bishop we can play bishop takes g5
or we have many other options actually
we can go d5 and knight e4
really cementing that outpost
okay bishop b3
so knight g5 is not scary
okay now we do not want to allow our
knight to get exchanged so this is a
no-brainer we want to play knight e4
we certainly do not want to allow bishop
takes c5
bishop d4 well that forces our hand
and we are more than happy to have our
hand for stroke g8 and look at this the
pressure on g3 has already grown totally
unbearable
white is losing
we have so many things that we can do
in the subsequent position and a bit
knight g5 okay this is desperation
how should we proceed
and this is easy at this point it's just
kind of like letting your hand
make the moves no come on guys come on
f6 knight takes c4
don't forget the knights are staring at
each other no you just play bishop takes
g5 don't overthink it bishop takes g5
and rook takes g5
and we're crashing through and attacking
g3 this is already essentially
resignable
this is already essentially resignable
um yeah rook takes g5
now we still need to be careful because
our king is not the safest so we cannot
relax
yeah now i think a lot of you are
already seeing the move if i
reading this correctly i think most of
you are going to be thinking one of two
moves either h4 attacking the g3 pawn or
the move d5 but d5 is stronger because
d5 improves the position of our knight
it it it cements the knight in place and
it opens up the queen which somebody
decided to put on c7 and it attacks g3
and the move h4 is going to be even
stronger once the queen is participating
in the action
so this is just totally unbearable
pressure not to mention that white is
down already two pawns
so you can see how nicely our setup came
together in this game
yeah queenie won
okay well i've already revealed the move
it's time to step on the gas pedal
and
just disappear the pawn on g3
now you might ask why not f4
f4 was also possible but i want the pawn
to remain on f5 in order to ensure the
long-term safety of the knight on e4 i
don't want to allow any shenanigans
in case one of the pawns has to remove
itself the other one is going to do the
do do the honors
my guess is that he's going to okay
bishop bishop b3
okay so there comes a time in games like
this when
you win a bunch of material
and then the absolute simplest method in
such positions is simplification
right people forget how effective the
method of simplification can be it
essentially eliminates the need to
calculate variations in many cases
simplifying is a total no-brainer as it
is here
just play rook takes g3
after rook takes you three don't even
think about it you are up three pawns
you're up three pawns
you have a monster knight on e4
the simplest by far is just to play
queen takes g3 i don't care if it's the
top computer move it doesn't matter you
know it wins and so you should play it
and of course h takes g3 to set up a
past pawn
knight takes you through would have been
a lot worse we don't want to move our
knight away from the outpost unless we
strictly need to now you might look at
this and say wait a second
isn't it annoying to give white a pass
pawn on h3
and understanding that the answer to
that question is no just comes from
experience right this pawn is a very
very long way away from promotion by the
time it even reaches h5 we're already
going to be steamrolling white in the
center
okay so several ways that we can win
this position
what i notice when i see this position
is two things the first is that our
priority is to set these pawns in motion
how do we set them in motion well we
should play f6 f6 and e5 at some point
but before we play f6 and e5 we haven't
completed the mission critical process
of activating all of our pieces let's
start with the patient move rook c8
attack c3
if white allows us to take on c3 we'll
take it
if he doesn't then maybe we'll play f685
but having the rook already active
will help us
uh more effectively set our center pawns
in motion again patient patience is very
important in these positions
and we don't need more pawns remember
the
the idea of diminishing returns when it
comes to material with every pawn or
equivalent that you capture
the value of subsequent material that
you capture diminishes and at some point
the curve really drops off when you're
already up a piece
taking another piece is usually
okay it's good but taking that first
piece was incomparably more important to
the evaluation
what should we do now well now we've got
a very vast choice
now going into minor psn games in such
situations is generally inadvisable of
course rook takes e3 is completely
winning oh actually it's so winning that
we can play it
but i actually like
uh well now rook takes e3 is easy though
yeah yeah no rook c3 is easy
now i would hesitate to play this move
if if if white's h pawn were let's say
already on h5 right if the h-bot
constituted a clear and present danger
we would have hesitated but here the h
pawn is way way way back and we're fine
how should we win this well ideally we
should win this without giving up the g3
pawn can we avoid giving the g3 pawn up
no
but can we use it as a bargaining chip
we can say okay i'm gonna give that pawn
up but you're gonna have to let me get
into a pawn end game how do we do that
yeah we can either drop the knight back
to e4 or we can move the knight into e2
either move is completely winning knight
e4 is more clinical because the knight
is on a defended square and now we
resort to we return to our old plan what
was our old plan
well we play f6 we play e5 and then d4
and the pawns are gonna totally
overwhelm white's pieces the game is
over
and okay here we don't even have to play
f6 we can just straight away play e5
okay we can just choose which pawn to
push i think d4 is easier because that
pawn is literally unstoppable d3 and d2
coming
yeah resigns i think white's going to
resign any second
yeah so here if you want to be like if
you want to be like super clinical what
should you play if you want to be
magnus carlson level surgical precision
not why f6 f6 is a completely
unnecessary move here the move has to
make sense f4 f4 cuts off the bishop a
common technique you build upon chain to
prevent the bishop from controlling one
of the key squares near the promotion
line
the bishop is trapped d3 d2 is coming
and the h pawn is way too slow
it's one tempo too slow actually because
bishop g7 d2 h6
d1 h7 you might say wait a second we
can't stop the pawn but obviously you
can checkmate the white king right you
have a tempo there
yeah d2
this is actually going to happen
now after h6 if you're worried about h7
you can always play knight e4
to g5
very nice
that was a nice game
all right so there's a couple of things
to unpack
so if you're a sicilian player you need
to know what you're going to do against
knight c3
a lot of players who are inexperienced
in
the sicilian or who just get started
let's say you're a night or flare right
and for those who don't know the night
or sicilian goes d6
d4 this is called the open sicilian it
is white's main line
takes takes knight f6 knight c3 now
there are four major sicilians in this
position
there's the night or if that's the move
a6 there's the classical or the rouser i
mentioned it that's the move knight c6
who can name the other two major
sicilians here there's a couple of minor
lines
but only two major lines the one is the
dragon g6 what's the other one
not the con let's see who knows the
other one
the other one is the least popular of
the big four e6 that's the chevening
again very good this used to be one of
the most popular moves nowadays it's
almost out of practice
um it's totally out of fashion but it's
still a legitimate move ray robson
actually was a big chevening gun guy a
couple years ago
um i think named after a city in in the
netherlands
there is also bishop d7
and there's the cotton hour variation
which is e5 but e5 is bad
because a bishop b5 check that's
actually why you play a6 you play a6 to
prepare e5
and to take away the b5 square
how come it's no longer a fashion the
reason it's no longer in fashion is
owes itself to paul karis
who developed the keras variation which
is g2 g4
and i think nowadays this is considered
to be a very very dangerous line for
black it's not losing it's not losing
but it's dangerous black is in some
trouble in this line
so by keeping the pawn on e7 you're
delaying g4
um and keras was this is called the
kerus attack g4
anyways anyways anyways um
let's say that you're a knight or flare
and let's say that your opponent goes
knight c3
now the problem with being a night of
player and playing the movie six
is that white can now say tricked ya
play knight f3 and then play d4 on the
next move and you have been move ordered
into either a con sicilian
or a taimanov or or i guess a
cheveningen but
not a night or because in the night of
the pawn remains on e7
so
the classic advice for knight or players
is to play the move d6 here
because now if white goes knight f3 we
go knight f6 and we're chilling
d4 you're taking go a6
um
if you are a
sveshnikov player or an accelerated
dragon player
you are recommended to play knight c6
because after knight f3 you can play the
accelerated with g6
or you can play you know the time if
you're a termata player you can
basically play anything you want
hopefully that makes sense so based on
which sicilian you play against knight
f3 that in turn determines your line
against knight c3
um it's like three different freeway
exits and you take one depending on
which sicilian you play
oh no the immediate g6 is fine uh fedese
have actually played this against me in
a classical game
yeah the immediate g6 is fine as long as
you're okay playing a dragon
in fact against vladimir i played knight
f3 and d4 because he wasn't a dragon
player at the time but it turns out that
he had prepared it for the tournament so
if you're a dragon player you can play
g6 yeah absolutely
so a6 is a good move if you're a night
off or
uh con or pow or um taiman of player
because here or a knight or player if
white plays knight f3 and you're a night
off player what should you play
interesting question for you guys if you
play the knight or sicilian and even
somebody who doesn't play the night or
can answer this question
how should black proceed if you're an
idol player here you should play d6
but not knight f6 because that allows
there's a bug that allows the nasty e5
you close the window
so
here you want to play d6 if you're an
idol flare
um and if you're a con player you should
play e6
now of course what i have left out is
that most of the time that people go
knight c3 they actually do not go knight
f3 on the next move they play one of two
openings
either the closed sicilian whale life
which is g3
very popular in the 70s and 80s still a
reputable variation or as most of you
have heard of the grand prix attack
where you play knight c3 and f4 now i've
played the grand prix with white in the
speedrun i won't get into the theory of
those openings
just remember you should have a line
against knight c3 for a sicilian player
so we played a6 white indeed played the
closed sicilian with g3
now we expand with b5
and a3 already i think is unnecessary
classic example of an automatic move but
in reality
i think b4
is not a dangerous prospect because
black's just pushing pawns and not
developing any pieces let's put it this
way i would not have played b4 in this
position we would have played bishop b7
anyway so a3 is a little bit timid it's
not terrible but it's a little timid it
gives us the tempo
so bishop g2 d6 and the reason this is
called the closed sicilian is because
white does not play d2d4 which is the
open sicilian the reason it's the open
sicilian is because the center gets
opened
the closed sicilian you normally pawn
not
available
knight f6
um
knight f3 bishop e7 still four games in
the database castles
now knight c6 ic has been played 12
twice but i don't really like this move
in these positions i prefer
to keep the knight on d7
um as i explained because
it does not obstruct the bishop we want
the bishops to be staring at each other
we don't bite that knight on c6 to be in
the way
so this is similar to a hedgehog setup
yeah you can definitely draw that
parallel
the hedgehog setup in its classical
uh instantiation goes
okay you can get the hedgehog through a
gazillion different move orders
but for example you can get um
a hedgehog through this line which is an
english line ricky one castles
e4 d6 d4 cd knight d4
and uh oh a6 actually blunders to e5
um but okay whatever it doesn't matter i
can just
basically this is the hedgehog
this is the hedgehog setup where you
have the shivan again pawns on e6 and d6
but here you have the pawns on b6 and a6
we have our pawns on b5 and c5
so i would say the setup that we adopted
is more active than the hedgehog
but it also is a little bit riskier
because we have more space
okay so h3
obviously white prepares to expand on
the king side with g4 now maybe it would
have been more consistent here for me to
play h5 immediately but we decided to
start with queen c7
now what would i have done in response
to the move g4 honestly i was fearing g4
a lot more than what he played
well after g4 i think black has a couple
of options we can play the move h6
and the point of h6 is not to stop g5 we
we can't stop g5 the point is to take
the sting out of that move why does h6
take this thing out of g5 because if y
plays g5 we take it white takes back
with the f1 and as a result of that move
who can tell me what square in the
center has been weakened by white and
this square in turn can be occupied by
one of black's minor pieces
it opens the f file but we don't give a
damn about this open file the knight's
going to jump into e5 in due time and
that's going to be one monster of a
knight
so like white weakens his control over
the key central squares e5 and d4
so we would have probably responded with
h6 now here our opponent uh carried out
this maneuver in the game 92 knight g3
but he did it one move too
quickly
i think here 92 would have been a lot
more effective and it's quite possible
that black should castle queen side
um i'm not totally sure what black
should do here it's a complicated
position
i've also seen
people try to sacrifice on the king side
of the move g5
but it's definitely too early for that
i would say that white is slightly
better here i would prefer white
so the setup that we adopted is
definitely dubious it's like
okay it's
a little bit iffy but it can really pay
off in a big way of white is not precise
which is what happened here
maybe we can also just castle
right and if white plays g5 we can still
go knight h5
and we can then secure that knight with
a move g6
but i don't like this as much i feel
like that knight on h5 is going to get
in trouble in the end
so
in any case at any rate white plays 92
giving us the opportunity to prevent g4
h5
a4 we play b4
and i actually think c3 is a very
serious i think it's one step in the
right direction or wrong direction
and after bc i think it was critical for
white to play knight takes e3 actually
i think after bc and c4 were clearly
better already because white's center is
just collapsing
white's entire center is collapsing in
contrast knight takes c3 would have kept
the white center intact because the move
c4 is no longer as effective why is it
no longer as effective because the
knight from c3
defends the pawn on e4 which means that
let's say white plays the same move from
the game knight g5
if we play the same move that we played
which is knight c5 now white can simply
play dc
now i can simply play dc so contrast
this position
to
this position the knight on e2 does not
defend e4
and so this pawn is a lot more poorly
defended
how would i respond to f5 asks
scour power well i assume you mean like
here if f5
well what are the options for responding
to f5 i think e5 is a great move just
closing the center
nothing wrong with the movie five
or
or we could play
well castling would be very risky
because now white has this move knight
g5 and this is super super nasty this
actually loses material so actually we
would play e5 that would be what we
would do e5
e5 and then maybe even d5 to reopen the
center on our terms
so it's very very nice to have this
bishop and to have this knight because
now we're going to play the move d5 and
we're gonna break up
white's pawn chain and create weaknesses
for example on f5
the knight on e2 is also very very bad
notice how it's restricted by the pawn
on e5
there's no access to any of these
squares nor does it have access to the
g3 square because white can't play g4
because we prevented it by playing h5
so f5 is not scary c3 bcbc c4
knight g5 and knight c5
and after if i think e5 is almost a
decisive mistake
what should white have done here
probably dc was the lesser evil but
if you look at this position or maybe
bishop takes e4 but even knight takes c4
we can cement that knight by playing f5
white's pawns are weak the g3 pawn's
weak white's in trouble here this is a
very nasty position
this is a very nasty position or we
could play bishop take c4 to trade to
trade uh the pieces i'm sure the engine
probably will find some way to stay
alive
um but after e5 we simply win a pawn and
we destroy
white center and we open up the g file
and we get ourselves the e4 of course we
just get all these advantages
jelly asks why did you trade the light
squared bishops and why had white
squared weaknesses well
i don't really think white had light
square weaknesses though right
i think the point of trading
light-squared bishops is just to weaken
white's king
right now the king safety is more
important than
any square complexes precisely because i
already know that i'm going to get the g
file and i already know that i'm going
to get the e4 square so removing the
bishop from g2 ensures that white's king
is going to be all alone there's going
to be no additional help in protecting
g3
so there was a question about why is
knight e4 such a dangerous idea if white
can just retreat the knight back to d2
and challenge the 94. two reasons
so
reason number one is that if we already
play rook g8 the pawn on g3 is going to
be hanging white's not going to have
time to play knight t2
what if white would have played knight
t2 here
well black has many ways to respond to
this
first we can play d5
and the knight is replaced by a pawn now
is the pawn as good as the knight no
it's still a pretty freaking sexy pawn
it's past it's protected so the outpost
is replaced by a pawn a common idea or
the outpost can be replaced by another
piece we can play the move queen c6 to
support the knight
and now the knight is replaced by a
queen the queen's also pretty darn good
here
so or
if you don't want any of that you can
just gobble up the pawn on c3 nothing
wrong with taking a free pawn
so logistically knight d2 is just not
scary for many many reasons my move
would be knight takes c3 yeah i think
knight c3 is best
now you would have to be a little bit
careful here because white is
threatening rook c1 right you have to be
careful not to lose your knight bishop
d4 is also a threat
so you can drop the knight back to d5
not as great of an outpost as e4 but a
pretty pretty good square
you know again great square
rook c1 we can just tuck our queen on d7
or we can
shift it to b7 and x-ray the king
probably even better
so
those are the reasons that knight d2
isn't scary now i agree bishop d4 loses
the game on the spot right bishop d4
literally helps us do what we wanted to
do anyway which is put the rook on g8
our opponent just lost the thread and
now h4 combined with the threat threats
against g3 are totally deadly the rest
of the game is very simple takes takes
takes d5 h4 etc we win all the pawns
so really if you think about it the the
climax of the game like the key points
lasted for only
like 10 moves or so right if we can say
it started around here when we exited
the opening
and by move 21 nine moves later we were
already totally dominating by move 22
exactly 10 moves later we were
completely winning
so it's interesting how quickly
these things tend to happen in these
complicated middle games
can you quickly talk about how you
changed your mind or the rook exchange
at the end you said it was an easy one
but before you weren't sure yeah
absolutely
so
i hesitated briefly because
essentially you have to be very very
careful right because knights are the
worst piece
at
stopping a past pawn
right if you have just a knight and
especially a corner pawn right the
h-pawn is the notorious enemy of the
knight so anytime i'm leaving myself
with a knight that faces against an
h-pawn i'm just naturally hesitant but
in this particular instance the king is
so
close to the pawn that it doesn't matter
what you have like it doesn't you don't
even need the knight to stop the pawn
you can just park the king on h7
i have an instructive example though of
when
like my opponent
greatly underestimated
the
importance of not allowing a situation
where you basically have a night trying
to stop a past pawn
so i want to show you guys this example
just to conclude the stream we had this
position
white is a pawn down
so my opponent is one upon it's an end
game upon down but something interesting
happens here so i started repeating
moves
i went queen c8 check
king f7
and queen c2 check
and i was expecting my opponent to make
a draw here but my opponent decides
to play knight back to g6 and this is a
huge mistake
because even though black is up upon
black has a knight the knight is
immobilized and white has upon majority
on this side of the board so what i did
was drop the bishop back to c3
attacking the pawn on a5 and after the
queen moves back to a8 to defend it i
made a very important move
my opponent greatly underestimated the
power of this move it's not a three b4
you can do something a lot better than
that
right don't just automatically say oh
i'm just going to create a pass pawn
that's cumbersome
and that's
black and tolerant that you play a4 you
fix the pawn on a dark square
and now all you have to do is basically
pre-move queen d2
and the knight is too far away to stop
the a5 font from falling my opponent
goes queen d5 bang you play queen d2
and the quench in the event of a queen
[ __ ] black is totally lost you're going
to take the pawn and the passers are
going to overwhelm the knight so my
opponent goes 97
i could have taken the queen here but i
decided to take the pawn first
now i drop the bishop back to b4
and here it was a no-brainer trade
queens it's a three on two black is up a
pawn but this isn't ev not even close f5
a6 and now bishop d4 ends the game
because if knight d4 a7 no forks
e5 bishop takes c5 right not even a7
first you take then we take and then we
come back to d4
and the bishop does absolutely
everything it destroys black's pawn mass
and it promotes the pawns
so
just a a game to hammer home the the
notion that you need to be very very
careful when you leave yourself with
only a night to fight past pawns
especially a corner pawn
but in this case
it's not dangerous but that is why i
hesitated very very briefly it's just
pure instinct
but again here you can just put the king
on h7 and the king will remain there
until the end of days
all right
i think that's where we're going to end
thanks for hanging out everybody have a
great start to your sun else tomorrow
bye
[Music]
you